yeah welcome to this video around six or
this supreme masters 2013 tournament
held in Norway in various cities and I
originally thought it would be in star
Wanga but this is just one location
amongst them the max Douglas yeah well
maybe around six now so I'm the standing
is that kayaking obviously still eats
with them plus 3 e 14 games then lost to
two thousand and thousand won that game
against Kye Arkansas p.m. ends on +1 the
same as Nakamura so one of those two
have had the chance to gag edge mera
pyaar kyun at least yeah let's go to
through the game some ant a quick
warning before I continue this video
this is Abby will be a bit shorter than
usually probably because I have some
obligations tomorrow morning so I cannot
um yeah go on the midnight off so much
this time okay so let's start with
topalov wang hao we have a queen's
gambit and one who plays the Scimitar
wash which is some somewhat popular
lately Kramnik has played this opening
in the candidates with the success and
yeah chrome [ __ ] always been a
trendsetter in the opening people copy
what he is doing because they trust his
quality preparation yet the polyp plays
III this is quite surprising it's not
considered to be critical move seat XD
night eggs and II form has long been
established as the way to go but ok
plate III after that one how can
transpose to various lines after 96 for
example we would transpose to the game
mcallen raja baath of today's
but when how took a different approach
he took on c4 which is also a good move
red transposes to the Queens gambit
accepted wear white has played the very
early move Knight to c3 and in the
Queens gambit except that you usually
don't want to do that as the night is
subject to two attacks by the beep on
gap and takes and this sets the tone for
the game to palaver immediately goes for
this end game here with the Queen trade
and he helps to get something on blacks
slightly exposed queenside pawns but
this is really very very little that
white can hope so we have from white
playing a form attacking this ball this
leads to further exchanges on the
queenside and f3 this is a very typical
move f3 is played to support efore and
prepare you for then why it has got the
better King in fact if we look at this
just proceed a couple of more moves to
see some more exchanges um and some put
exactly that on the board when I first
first saw this position during the
broadcast thought I was looking now i'm
following this mostly on my mobile phone
when i've got a small break in the
office um the other i saw this i thought
okay this looks like the power of might
be able to to put put it on and some
pressure because ok this pawn is a bit
loose it's it looks weaker than the
beach upon and of course why does just
quicker with the king is some just
put this this edition of the body is
just quicker however the problem is
after King III which the power of plate
while help lady five and then we see
that his pieces have set up yeah Barry
on the fourth rank and the White King
that is the main Trump at least some
paper isn't isn't doing so much in fact
it seems that white cannot make any
substantial progress in fact I think in
this position if white is going to try
for anything then he probably must play
the movie 5 preventing e65 and really
allowing on of them allowing the King 22
to activate of course it gives like this
great square on d5 but still the game
continues and I think white still has
some slight chance to do something
against the pawn it probably is a draw
with the precise play but this is I
think what why should have tried to to
put some pressure on black yeah frankly
speaking as strong as a player
topologies those very young yeah those
slow technical positions are not his
absolute strength I mean this but
possible that the player like cars or
chronic can make a 60 70 game out of
this and really a test lacking in some
way but ok I'm not saying that I
analyzed it very deeply the only thing
is that this definitely leads to nothing
am shuffled a couple of times and agree
to draw it's not exactly am great
performance here by by white choosing
this quite unambitious opening and then
not even trying in the end game if you
play such a slow opening you really need
to be ready to to push on
lucky five maybe though I admit that
probably it is a draw anyway okay so not
much happening in this game um let's
look at our own young against hammer
next um where is it yeah and we have a
group thought the wrong place the rupee
one line I think this is a recent
addition to his repertoire and I have a
hard time at the moment to remember he
has played this before recently not
quite sure against against I went to but
ok it's not a surprise for hammer he
obviously had something prepared and he
had prepared this Queen a5 check line
where you grab the a to pawn now castles
and we should be for this has been
played brilliant more than 1,000 games I
I guess hundreds of times and it's been
very heavily analyzed the main move now
is some Bishop to g5 um but in the game
here only unplayed rook takes b7 and I
what I did is at least them for this I
and look to look at this position up in
the on recently yeah God one half years
ago released a book by Boris of rooks
the Israeli well Massa if he wrote a
two-volume book on the groom felt and in
this book he gives this Linus the most
reliable foot like to equalize it's
still long and complicated variations
but
it did equalize at the end according to
his his book tomorrow ever played knight
c6 and after this we quickly get a
position and that is very very concrete
why detects the night and okay he took
on a three and then got the night to d4
and yeah what is rook doing on 7th
eating pawns so why does app own app but
black has them of course I want to play
with the a pond and you can be sure
almost that this has been on on the
preparation born before the game however
looking at how mas clock you already had
spent like 30 minutes on this which
frankly speaking as far too much if you
play such a frosting opening actually on
that level I think you can only pay this
if you have analyzed it down to a cross
draw anything else's is murderous okay
rook takes seven and 85 um I did some
brief um analysis some on this game but
not very m detail because it is fairly
complicated and to be honest I'm not a
big fan of this kind of chess where you
just play like almost 20 year moves off
preparation and then it's a pure
calculation job if you if it is a draw
on or wins or whatever it's very
time-consuming to analyze and and
difficult to assess with the limited
time I can invest maybe an hour invested
a little bit more than one an hour for
preparation of this video enter this
very complicated position would take
much more time um to really assess and
then I would I don't know solve them
probably rather important branch of the
group for defense
so I cannot cannot really do that what I
know is after a five that are 36 a four
and each 5k this position now i cured
and right here hama already made a
mistake which probably cost the game and
this just shows them to be honest a very
bad preparation Aronian has played the
rupee one line before and you cannot
after nineteen moves down to 40 minutes
and and have such a forcing position on
the board I mean this is just asking
asking for a lot of for loss in which
probably Aronian didn't make a single
move on his own but its all preparation
so tell it's a possible at least yeah he
played them the move Queen to be too
it's very difficult to tell all that
apart the problem with this move is
basically at it detects the porn but
like you not take it and therefore this
move is probably without without a big
point it seems that um something like a
three and then probably dropping to see
for its better at least this is the
result of them brief engine supported
analysis in fact as a human player if
you try to analyze this kind of position
um you take ages because it's so so
tricky to to analyze with the a pond and
the computer probably solves this
position completely but it takes it
takes a very long time it seems that
this is the tougher defense which should
be three quincy form the main point is
that the Queen controls the d5 square so
this activation move is not possible in
the game be played as mentioned Queen B
2 and white can just ignore this he paid
Bishop e3 which is strong this allows
this move at some point
most importantly prepare screen to d5
the problem is it is not even a tech
this phone if black would take then
there's Queen d5 attacking the bishop
and if it retreats why it simply takes
on f7 and wins the queen is really a
powerful piece you'll get this oops a
line like that is just flat-out winning
blacks got no way to defend this
position you put chance to pick that up
and end the deep one simply simply far
too strong yeah this is why black cannot
take it and in the game may have played
a three and then the very strong but
obvious Queen d5 yeah the queen is so
strong here it snow threatening rook
takes f7 and black must really attend to
that you cannot ignore it if you play a
to for example there's really rook f7
and the promotion is is useless check
king and takes and that's it note the
bishop here on just over like cannot
cannot promote and he has no move in
this position as writer threatening all
those discovered discover checks or
maybe m MV seven or something it's just
just terrible like must react on Queen
g5 you cannot just move the ipod and the
possible idea would be to play the rook
to be eight to the other it's all under
fire on on a eight but this is also
excellent for what you can try for a
concrete win with e6 probably
successfully or just play F for which is
easier the idea is simply that a to
filestube
and white picks up the pawn of course
you wouldn't go a a 2 then but what is
like smooth now he doesn't have anything
going for him white can just go at seven
and not their thing maybe with ideas
like this pick up the pawn the bishop on
g7 is called this is a problem the a
porn is a dangerous pawn very often and
mostly due to the combination with the
bishop controlling the promotion square
but well look at this bishop it is
imprisoned here on g7 now so on okay it
is imprisoned um so f4 is probably the
easiest wing yeah in the game hi MA
played rook a2a 888 and yeah this is can
be answered simply by taking d7 look the
eight Bishop g5 and resigns yeah a bit
of a bit of a poor game I mean web-like
must be honest about this you cannot
play in this kind of tournament and
reinvent the sharpest line or one of the
sharpest lines of the group read over
the board I mean not quite sure what
what the point was um and around here if
you look at it with the computer and it
gives right already a very very clear
edge so it's like walking into an
interim into into a pit fall right out
of the opening to choose this variation
it really seems that a Brooks
recommendation of taking and taking f3
taking before it's the much easier way
to play also from a practical point of
view and
just let's just back what is analyzed in
this book is also very complicated and
needs to be learned in a way but one
important point is at least from a
practical point of view that this deep
one is gone and this corner center was
the main problem in the game with the
quick strong deep own of course you know
that in the Guru thought but it's really
a good thing if you can take off the
spawn of course this is very complicated
and technically and just look at this
will be attacking here attacking here
and so on it's it's a very complicated
line and this is typical Greenfeld stuff
for mean if you play as the sharpest
lines and this opening you basically
need to analyze and learn it up to the
very end some lines and this is one of
them you can just learn it and not
played over the world when you can but
then you shouldn't complain if you lose
some games like this okay um next game
let's go to Nakamura against us with
love where is it oops no here Nakamura
against swidler let's see what happens
like I'm we're on +1 so um a further win
would be excellent and he's going for
the poinciana opening and this really
weird opening is experiencing a slight
revival after Carlton has played it in
the invite Gonzi and a couple of runs
legend was even played them by former
booboo woman world champion who you fun
against carless black so um yeah and I'm
glad that swidler now place the move
that I I play I can't see three and
basically considered to be to be
excellent he plays d5
and nakamura answered Queenie for this
is no a surprise the the old main line
or the outline of the bronze gianni was
Bishop b5 but this is what should we
reviewed it by by this it's a it's
pretty complicated but like is almost
winning out of the opening in this line
if you want more on this check my
channel and look at the repertoire
suggestion with a 45-foot blank I made a
separate video on the prongs gianni
we're also looked at the move played in
the game this is queenie for this is
just better in comparison to we should
be five still not something that needs
some too frightened like my recommended
move in the in the video was f6 and this
position which is simple and good it
protects the attacked d5 pawn and like
just intends to complete development we
should be 697 it's not so clear what
white is actually doing in this position
it seems that very often d3 and quincy
to is relatively best way to play with a
reverse funny door and this isn't
exactly great for what so I'm not quite
sure why they why they play this opening
so okay but sevilla is playing something
else and quite an interesting setup you
played Knight f6 looks like a blunder at
first but the test got some points it's
a sacrifice which would be six now and
96 meeting c6 so white has played a
queen move he moved once twice and third
time with the night and lost lots of
time in the meantime black has developed
so it is some compensation for the porn
um here white can even try to snatch
another pond but this is this is really
too much just just for argument's sake
have a look at this
this position I think it's really quite
funny where black has got everything had
developed and wide only has moved her
this pronto to a nonsense square and
moved the Queen okay what what is
winning basically what cannot take on c6
of course so d3 was played which shows
secures the center but black very
quickly as we see here gets play em
based on this piece activity and white
can easily get into trouble if he plays
some to um yeah too greedy like this
taking which would be for just to show
what what what might happen yeah black
gum is basically winning already has all
kinds of stuff is now threatening would
be 89 oops nanite of4 and so on the king
is in the center it can be a really good
experience this this game so when a
camera is playing is perfectly right he
covers to the pond and after Bishop g4
just retreats this leads to this
position well at first you think all
right White has consolidated and turn
where's blanks compensation um damn
black and factors is fine here but he
needs to to do one thing he needs to a
disposition play the important move 19th
before this is of course essential
otherwise um black wheel would be almost
clear for now the point is after this
there's Queen to h4 and get the normal
covering move f3s ghats not permitted so
there's no way to tell the night
and it's obviously pinned on the y en
default um so what is why it's supposed
to do we played the best move here okay
white can also play a slow movie like g3
frog that but not gesture just to show
something like this was possible in a
very safe position that white never ever
is going to reduce but probably never
ever is going to win but Nakamura always
wants to fight so he played the much
more interesting with G formed breaks
this on the forthright and forces like
to play a five no other move this is the
technical way to proceed if Y it now
takes we get to the game probably get to
the game but black has got some
additional options he played the move
Bishop in three witches I think the best
this basically forces root checks before
and make sure that you get this position
if you would take here black has
additional ideas you can even play a
strange move like rupee aid and delay
all this so playing Bishop e3 is just
much easier to calculate as black now
must play with tanks this is nonsense of
course by with you block the rook here
with the youth de-spawn so group takes
plate and then takes on f5 this is just
simpler and queen age three was played
yeah here um black had other options as
well if we take stop we see that black
is one porn down but he's got this play
in the e-file and of course got active
pieces White's ropes are not connected
and the king is only one
so it looks like a decent conversation
the easiest in fact was the move from
bishop to have for long castles and then
maybe something like we g5 then attacks
f5 and gets the porn back I don't think
that do item has got anything here it's
about the body put probably spill I
played Queen h32 to attack the pond and
this gave white a little something maybe
but and I let's say if there is
something than it is for why'd you play
deaf six now and of course this is a bit
annoying you cannot now capture the
spawn with them with a piece and you
also of course and you don't want to
take I mean look at this there's just
the G file open and this must be in a
way better for white so I think swidler
played much better he retreated the
Queen and allowed the capture on g7 and
now we have this typical type of
position where the the pawn is actually
a good shield for for the black side it
doesn't really matter so much that wider
took all this why did the moment has got
two extra points but black of course is
very active the problem is white cannot
cancel short don't make any sense and if
it cancels long maybe we should put
blacks move on the bathroom piayed
activating the rook yeah then this is a
bit of a problem for why he cannot
easily play wrong castles for example as
the pawn is saying and how do you
coordinate here a camera plate be 32 to
cover just put it on the board this is
the problem and then white skin is very
insecure so b3 plate and spadina
immediately goes for for the counter
play with a five
this wasn't the only movie also could
have played Bishop f4 but it seems in
general I think the sole game looks like
very decently a very decently played I
didn't other computer let's say didn't
find any substantial improvement form
from both sides it seems like black is
simply too active here and we'll get
material back in the game we got to be
three back end this is g7 porn is also
in all sorts of scenarios with brother
exchanges this part is basically gone
and this foster the draw with the
perpetual yeah I think a pretty correct
game I'm gonna come watch ridin off bid
opening but swidler was certainly
prepared for this um yeah I think it's
clear that he had some preparation s
Tarleton has has had played it before he
played in the candidates um together
with the magnas so it was clear that he
had something against the kanji on e and
this this was the line um yeah in fact
as mentioned on my recommendation is to
play f6 but the the way here that soon
love played nine f6 seems seems fine
interesting interesting way to go okay
so draw no wind form Hikaru to catch up
with the top so let's look at the
tournament leader now on and kayaking
and this was unfortunately a rather long
game came we have a uno pass and
kayaking is playing the double in you
know these days am I on displaying d3 he
actually am from a very long time um
mostly only played that the Berlin end
game and he had very good score with
this but recently it seems to have lost
faith in this
in fact one of my nicest chest memories
is some about I let me think about this
it's a couple of years ago maybe seven
eight years ago when i was playing in
the bundesliga so first league in
Germany we had some the very nice
opportunity to play against the multiple
German team champions baden-baden where
are not this plane he plays a couple of
games per year not like all games but
like three or four and it was very nice
that he played against us so we face the
team with sheer off on swidler and donna
donna playing on 11 and i was the team
captain of the opposing team i didn't
play we always alternated on the on the
last couple of brats I would have played
not one of those top GM's but reg
Regular GM but this day I was a teen
cabinet was very nice to watch him Alan
play and also watch him analyze after
the game was very very nice friendly
person so it's awesome and the way I
remember this in this in this league
game against them Grandmaster lambda he
played also castles and they play at the
end game in which she won a very nice
and game ok so I'm got to be distracted
from this game ok um but I'll not to the
plate d3 and this is what he usually
does nowadays again the bobbin after
Bishop c5 he exchanged and we have this
structure that we see quite often
nowadays some of this entire Berlin Wall
end game with this doubled pawns it's
very static and it is at best very very
slight edge for what we see that in the
game I don't want to spend too much time
on this black goes from this typical
maneuver this is a well-known
way to play wyd exchanged the bishops
here and place the night on III it's all
very very logical in a way queen d forum
I surprised me a bit but okay he wants
to go to see three the main feature of
this position is of course of the pawn
Chainz white is got this very stable
pawn chain that only it can be attacked
at at the bayesian c2 and this is very
nicely protected by this night and this
formation on the queenside means it here
the play is basically frozen like
doesn't really have any way to to make
any progress on the queenside the only a
theoretical thing I could do was look
like be 5c 5 c4 and this is very very
theoretical I mean in the process you
weaken yourself so much that you
probably lose material that means the
queenside is frozen and in the meantime
on white maybe he has got some chances
on the King side he can prepare f4 for
example which is the typical way to to
make some some progress um however it is
not all bad for black black is so very
very solid but he cannot do much really
black has no way to out of the pawn
structure and this also means that white
is the one who a little bit dictates the
game he can try at least something more
black is basically just just staying and
tries to defend but which is not
terribly dramatic but it's not like
black can't do anything he centralized
protected the porn and now we should
play G for this is an interesting choice
I was more expecting a preparation form
for f4 but G for his own it's an
interesting move it Bloxham any kinds of
f5 ideas that black Yong Yong didn't
prepare but it's a possibility it blocks
all that it's a a preparation before
night f5 in some positions not at the
moment doesn't really bring any benefits
but it improves that and why it still
has those ideas with f4 and and so on on
we see that in the game kya can quickly
blocked here the further g porn advanced
and island was very busy getting this
important moving to be sure to make any
sort of progress on the King side and I
was not playing for draw me hables
playing actively I think in this
position on kayaking who was a bit down
on time we see that he spent quite some
time to set up this position this might
be surprising on because it looks like a
very unspectacular game but the problem
is that those kind of positions way of
don't really have any active play
yourself on are tricky you tend to spend
too much time figuring out which line
you you do need to choose which is all
lines or slightly worse but which one I
going to play it is there may be one of
those lines that look slightly worse
that in fact much worse so he was a bit
of bound but I'd bit down on time here
however I think he and he had a good
chance and I'm slightly surprised that
he didn't play that it it's it's the
first move that I've thought of and in
fact the engine approves it's funny this
doesn't happen so often but my first
idea was to to play this counter move
for h5 it's like a bit like fight fire
with fire but it seems to be good the
ideas that of course the skin isn't so
great on H
and like is quick with Luke edge aid to
me it seems that this move from
basically solve some blacks problems
instantly but at some something like
this for example Black is very quick the
best that white can do is something like
this and this is really leading to two
not much the King side gets traded off
and I don't see white winning any sort
of game with this these simplifications
and that's not even the only way to play
like it has got some some alternatives
if white takes here like and just oops
take on g4 and after this set up
something like like this intending to go
Brooke h3 this Bishop is not not a bad
piece now it looks rather active there
are some positions where even though
black might be the one to dictate the
events h5 seems like a good move to me I
don't really see a big thing that I can
try one one way could be no this was
played h5 could be maybe the smooth
arguing that here black probably is
playing g4 and now maybe with some very
M elaborate maneuvers white can try to
play a three like rook here and prepare
three and so on but I don't really
believe it I don't believe that this
will lead to anything I can always play
a defensive move like this basically I
think h5 would have been much easier he
played on Luke g8 and set up set up a
more passive set up and set up a more
passive set up this is great English and
set up an orphan and sort of a more
passive position um only now he went for
b5 getting a counter play on the
queenside one idea also could be to
simply close
the position are completely and this is
was also not in nawlins interest he
suddenly wanted to try something sister
is clear played through gauge to
intending to open up the edge farland
invade with the rook rook g7 takes and
will be one Yahoo p oneness a bit of a
funny move but it is an open file if
black rep's upon and he did that I think
is also the right choice black shouldn't
stay passive p.m. I move like this is
just I just awful leaving wide with the
only opened file he grabbed the Cremona
this is the right decision and king a
queen to you one and our wives ideas
rook to a one and two get the palm back
yeah how to assess this position now
it's a probably somewhere between a
slight edge who write and and equal but
it is tricky to play for black I mean I
would in a practical game I would much
prefer to play wide simply because this
night is such a great piece it is
protected by the poor cannot be attacked
and it covers all the crucial squares
see to pawn g4 porn it can go to f5
maybe it can go to d5 if the sea pawn
should move at a later stage this is
just an excellent piece only three so
very rare I mean nights on e3 and d3
have very very reality good pieces but
here they are here is an excellent night
and white has good chances to to get the
corn back in any case we see that in the
game
all made some progress he increased the
pressure but didn't get the poem back
immediately and now I found a good idea
to make a progress he got the light
after a couple of moves yeah that's do
smoke quickly got the night to be five
and by now it is really tricky for like
maybe there's still some way to defend
it but in a practical game that it is
difficult it is especially difficult to
not take on d5 I think black needs to do
that the night is just too strong he
took and played the roof to d8 whoopsie
one trying to get the phone back Andrew
please apnea okay why doesn't want to
exchange if you've got this pressure on
legs position you've are reluctant to
exchange you want to keep pieces on the
world and this rook h3 is actually a
rather strong rules that has got to this
idea with an attack and it got its got
an additional idea but funny enough this
is realized that the game will see that
now rook a five whoopsie for and now I'm
it is really difficult like if you just
give away the a porn then white will
just have a better position without any
porn deficit those pawns will still be
weakened the king is also week so we
decided to cover the a poem and here is
a very interesting moment on here with
the really easy newsgroup take c5 um
honored could have won the game he must
have had some serious miscalculation
because this is just the first move you
think of it is can maybe it is really
the case that after group c 5 he he
didn't really see this d4 maybe
d force is very strong this the Queen
move of course sets up and pin you
cannot take because of the Queen so
white plays this move and now the rook
on edge dream suddenly covers the Queen
so the rubies hanging and this means
over black black is just busted now
white got the palm back and he's got all
the positional troms in this position
storm just over default is strong on
this one and really strong and move 49
here I'm really really let alone why
didn't he take on c5 I have no idea he
played the move up to age one and now
after Queen B 5 everything is protected
it seems that now like can draw
relatively easily we can push the a porn
white will we get this pawn a couple of
more moves get this pawn but black in
return enters with the Queen and it's
impossible to actually prevent perpetual
cm why it took here and now this one
sets up this threat of Queen h1 even
winning so the only thing that white can
can do is to sector look and go for
perpetual they immediately agree to draw
him so this is just just a perpetual for
both sides in I mean look at this can
you give it up now I shouldn't give up
the roof so always check but it's a
perpetual in any kind of where you can
think of so I'm a big opportunity for
Anand here the caption c5 really wasn't
difficult and and it is winning after i
didn't i didn't have the chance to look
at the
that the postgame interviews where they
sometimes tell why they didn't choose a
certain move and off this is an
explanation why an something wasn't
played and whether the the blunder in
this in this line was one what didn't he
see we're really the default for
something else I don't know yeah okay
this was announced Gary could have won
against the leader and this would have
made everything much more more exciting
but he didn't manage okay so we have
only Carlton's game left it is quite
often the case that is last game so can
I hit the wrong button where is it
carlton against the java so what kind of
opening 12 is going to play this time
it's a symmetrical English with III um
yeah guys playing all openings what can
you say um this is not one of the most
ambitious slides one good response for
example is the movie 5 which is tough
for white to play for an advantage
against or interesting is also the move
g6 transposing to oops into a pan of
this line has been discussed recently
numerous times galfer dentists on the
board couple of times he lost against
our only on one game and the candidates
an early game okay but a job offer goes
for classical kind of setup he plays
ecigs which is perfectly all right of
course d4 d5 and we come to the soul of
declined tarish defense simular to the
top all of one how game here white can
do numerous things an interesting move
for example is to keep the tension with
a 30 jahre but the causal immediately
went for this truck
exchanging on d5 and playing Bishop to
b5 in fact after we should be six
councillors castles and takes we reached
a position that is basically a
Rubenstein news of Indian with Carlos
reversed and white having an extra move
being white in the in the Rubenstein you
only at this moment would have played
knight c6 in this case here in 93 and it
would be a would be black smooth here it
is white white smooth so on he uses the
extra move to prepare the fianchetto um
yeah how to assess this position it's
prone am around equal white after a
couple of moves exchanged on c6 after
being provoked with a six and then this
kind of structure we have the typical
struggle where black has got slightly
weaker queenside pawns he's got a type
of hanging horns yep or I'm not sure
about the English an English expression
that some and an isolated before my
isolated pawn with the with a
neighboring porn um it's a subtype of
hanging porn okay those pants are
slightly weak we see that the rook is on
the sea far and still it's hard to
believe that black should have any
serious problems in fact after a couple
of moves if we put this on the board
Magnus managed to get some pressure here
again through sports and a job of felt
inclined to after this now we see that
root C 1 and here further client to with
the sea porn and set up this poor
information which is in itself slightly
weak but then you have this Bishop and
now it gets three curious this is a
only looking at its own porn it is clear
that white has got little something it's
not so clear however how much of a
little something it really is can you
can you get anything substantial out of
this here one possibility was a very
concrete one to play going to be five
and trying to snatch pawns and it seems
that it really is winning upon but black
has ideas for counter play you can for
example for the moment ignore the pawn
and let same play this just for
argument's sake set up a position like
this where you basically have sacrificed
the 8th porn but in return you get quite
some some play against this and maybe
you can even simplify further with
advances of the spawns it's not clear I
mean it is an important sacrifice that
can be probably at best equal for black
or give him sufficient compensation it
was interesting queen bee 5 but i think
what Karl's did was also good he played
eform and this is a rather typical of
his attorney wants to have a one-sided
structures that he can play on form for
a long time to grind the opponent down
um here it is the structure the
structure that he wanted to reach with
those bad pawns and the bed Bishop for
the pawns against the night and in fact
we get this end game here at first you
might think oh this is x over white I'm
going to torch him forever against those
parts and this is maybe am on the case
if white would have like one or two
extra moves let's say white would would
have the possibility to get the night to
be too and centralized the King given
two extra moves and then like will
suffer forever the thing is in this
there's repudiate the idea being to
activate the rook King news and now a
for this is super important without this
idea black really would be in trouble
here with a for Andrew D for his manages
to get rid of one of those pawn
weaknesses he had two pawns that were
weak and now it's only one policy pawn
this happened and now here yeah let's
have a look at this how to assess this
position this is in fact in a way easy
hit anyway difficult the easy part is
you can see that with this locate on c4
black really suffers from a very limited
bishop and white is the only one
especially considering that he's got
this apron is the only one to to try
anything black can only stay and wait
proceedings so why this in a way always
slightly better this is without any any
question the difficult assessment is and
I'm I'm sorry to say that I cannot
really tell even after some analysis I
cannot really tell how much of an
advantage it really is should white when
we're super precise play should like
draw or what kind of assessment is fair
here um I white is some better the
question is can can you win or is it not
possible let's continue for a while I
think the real essential on things
happened somewhat later both sides I'm
activate kings and we have some space
gainers but like we see that Carlton is
basically just shuffling it's um it's
often a very good policy to do just that
simply not
commit to anything and just see what the
other side is doing in fact here it is
also on a position where blacks choice
is very limited look at this you don't
want to really move the rook that would
make the king um yeah move on again
you're not tied to the defense of the
the night you cannot really move the
bishop this is too easy you don't you
don't have many moves so you push those
King side parts in the meantime look a
six the white also could have gone all
over the king but mobilizing the Rope is
probably the in better decision now the
lib enters and well there is nothing bad
already happened noises it's perfectly
all right rubber plug is doing you
played f5 this surprise melon that like
um without being too heavily provoked
changed the pawn structure an advanced
here on the King side it doesn't seem to
be so great but I don't think it also
should should use or anything it seems
though that something like this giving a
check and putting this Bishop on you for
it seems that this was some bit more
solid anyway but still it is a nagging
edge for white you always have this
ideas and you must be very very careful
as black now okay and once the Honda on
the kingside white pushed here and now
black went 4-4 town to play with rook
entering White's camp
ne5 and root g one yeah black is trying
to use the rope here from the from the
first rank and i think by now with those
born advances it gets slightly critical
for black you certainly cannot afford
any big big missteps a six and rook e1
check for us okay yeah of course wide
needs to react to the check um here on
most spectators were surprised that
cards was playing king c3 and not King
a2 yeah of course I was surprised as
well this looks some yeah much easier
with them with some critical lines one
line is Luke be ain't I think this is
bad actually because of a seven you know
if you move the look it gets very simple
again but black can take here and give
up the exchange and this is not not
completely trivial to win I mean
probably you should win but it's not
completely completely a trivial um this
is an important important point maybe
here but it still needs to be here to be
played out however this shouldn't be a
line that Carson um wants to avoid the
other line however that i'm going to
show now is quite curious i'm not i'm
not sure about this route before this is
um this is a possibility and here the
question is what wider should play the
the easiest way at first seems to be 93
check IAM after which um this is going
to happen
until your first reaction is all right
i'm behind the pawn business winning
pushing the poem basically supporting
the porn but the thing is we have a look
at this position how is white going to
win now I'm not sure I mean this is an
interesting feel to look at if you have
some time on your hands has one does
right have any chances to win this
position I'm really not sure you can
never promote the pawn without the King
helping and somehow blacks king is very
active how does right enter the position
somewhere here here yeah well once you
advance with the king then you know
there's also a seat porn I'm not sure if
you if you give the engine this
pollution it tells you plus want
something 1.2 1.3 yeah this is more mice
but how actually do you win I have
played this a bit against the computer
and it didn't do anything as white and
seems there's nothing I mean this was
also my human assessment before I even
switched on the thing I thought okay how
I'm going to win now um this seems
tricky however here white also has got
the it seems strong move Knight be too
so maybe a bit counterintuitive to to
place the light on be too but right
canvases in porn square and IP to seems
to lead to seem silly to a good position
for white in 70 k 8 and now on where my
notes yakkung be free of course
something like this might be a quite
interesting option form for white with
Vegas of you look at this um
I should you give the check not sure
yeah probably should King a 5 root here
and at the end white is one DF porn and
this you can also play on forever have
some chances to even get to get to the
h1 at the end this patent might offer
more realistic chances to win then the
Ruby end game this rook endgame that I
showed before it's just not clear to me
if white white children yeah Council
played King to c3 which was yeah call to
blunder initially in the broadcast or
not in the broadcast button by lots of
people who watched it with with the
computers because they thought that the
king air to was winning it I'm not so
sure okay rajamma Fredrik see one I'm
strangely enough spending more than 10
minutes in the process this was some
very surprising because it looks like
the normal the normal thing to do and in
addition the Kings in through the Kings
III was about some escape we can see now
that in this position wide can white
could play King b3 and this intact leads
to a similar variation to the one we we
saw before oh oh it's even identical
right yeah this is identical so on this
sum is just a transposition car driver
played king d3 answered by would be one
I now look a one yeah text the phone
not much choice why does going for
tactics here like not place King c6 what
happens if like takes it look here and
press the Kings supposed to go
everywhere you go if you've got a got a
really nasty check coming so I twins
material for example this attacks just
too much kinsey sicks plate and now 95
backyard all based on a concrete
calculation attacking the bishop now
yeah and in fact him kayaking with two
minutes on the clock made the probably
decisive mistake with the move like
bouquet to we could have continued the
game still in trouble but he played this
and this loses instantly this was also
very much fraud upon mana camera who
simply couldn't understand how could how
can he play this move I mean because the
response is so obvious at least to him
and it was played by by cars would be
six check King c4 only move unite III
check now you cannot go here because of
this Big Fork so this is the only move
and then the midpoint f4 and this is
what Carl said that how can you not see
that oh yeah you can overlook all kinds
of stuff with two minutes on the clock
but I in some way agree if you are on
that level you probably should see this
kind of tricks even with low time of
course this is the simple point winning
a piece and yeah this Bishop
doesn't really have any greater swears
to go to to enter before and now f5 is
gone and age for this week as well yeah
now it is to get to this famous saying a
matter of technique of technical play
and Carlton does a good job after root
page one he goes 96 and now the seaborne
is falling yeah here black also could
have proved taken but look like this
there's still this hanging and it's it's
just too much no way to do to keep this
position together as black plate king d3
captured here now the rook returns to
support the a porn and after rook a 3
here our job of resigned there's simply
no one no way to go for example
something like this where's the Kings
supposed to go this oops promotes and
okay this is just the bishop and white
is sweating completely so a second win
for Carlton in a row he's on plus two
now just have a point behind crackin so
he still got chances and this is in a
way a typical Carlton game he exploited
those arrows in the end game and there's
also a typical video of mine I keep
telling at the beginning this is going
to be shorter and at the end it's over
one hour again I simply cannot do this
this lack of short videos whatever I
hope you enjoyed it I think the games
actually am you could have analyzed some
would deeper but and
didn't managed in temp firm the time to
to invest um yeah interesting chassis
I'm from Norway and we can look forward
to interesting final three runs with
carbon trying to catch Moroccan it could
have happened today if honors would have
taken the c5 phone near the end yeah
thanks for watching I'll be back
tomorrow